[Musique]
plus de cinquante mille personnes ont
tenu à se déplacer pour le saluer
dernière fois puis il a quitté le
parlement
[Musique]
le moment est impressionnant l'émotion
est à son comble ça va maintenant aux
états unis parce que c'est le plus grand
suspense électoral de l'histoire
américaine après l'élection d'hier on ne
saura pas avant demain et peut-être même
la semaine prochaine qui sera le nouveau
président des états unis
cette opération de sauvetage pourraient
se poursuivre pendant encore plusieurs
jours
hier soir c'était la première fois qu'en
maintenant en vigueur ce nouveau plan
d'urgence
[Musique]
c'est toujours pas ce qui s'est passé
qu'on est en train de faire c'est de
sécuriser le site pour permettre
justement aux enquêteurs d'aller
fouiller d'aller chercher ce qu'ils
cherchent des sites trouver les indices
nécessaires
avec ce disque ont peut-être le plus
important de sa carrière presque
maniglier de pousser au coût de murs et
des facteurs en leur disant que s'il
refuse de le suivre dans cette aventure
de nouveaux partis ce qu'ils acceptent
de voir petit dôme art ribéry le bilan
pourrait s'alourdir au cours des
prochains jours la bactérie e.coli a
comme caractéristique qu'elle peut
sommeiller jusqu'à 10 jours dans le
corps des humains avant de se manifester
l'un des moteurs de l'appareil et des
gens feu lorsque l'avion commence à
prendre de la vitesse
là il a plané comme ça il est tombé d'un
coup air france a annoncé que tous les
vols du concorde sont annulés jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
[Musique]
des centaines d'admirateurs du rocket se
sont massés le long du parcours pour
saluer une dernière fois leur idole
là
[Musique]